doha il s'agit donc d'un procès tendu
entre républicains et démocrates
hakima électrique avec une première
journée qui a donné le ton de ce procès
historique qui s'est ouvert hier
il aura fallu 13 heures aux sénateurs
pour approuver la résolution
républicaine qui va qui a déterminé en
fait les règles du jeu comment va se
dérouler ce procès de l'encadrement des
déballeurs sans surprise la résolution a
été votée elle 53 voix contre 47
on sait désormais que les sept élus
démocrates de la chambre des
représentants qui font office de
procureur vont présenter aujourd'hui
leurs arguments en faveur de la
condamnation de donald trump pour abus
de pouvoir et entrave à la bonne marche
du congrès ils auront 24 heures sur une
période maximum de trois jours pour
convaincre les sénateurs de la
culpabilité de donald trump dans la
sphère ukrainienne puis les avocats de
trains port ont exactement le même temps
c'est à dire 24 heures sur trois jours
pour présenter leur défense
enfin les 100 sénateurs 53 républicain
et 47 démocrates auront 16 heures pour
poser des questions par écrit aux deux
camps alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que juste avant ce vote sur la
résolution de l'encadrement du procès de
donald trump et bien les démocrates ont
présenté onze abandonnant tous ont été
rejetés des amendements dont l'immense
majorité visait à convoquer des témoins
clés mais également à exiger de
l'administration trump a présenté des
documents qui sont liées au dossier
ukrainien pour les démocrates ce procès
est truqué d'avancé car les républicains
ont rangé les règles du jeu en cours
justement cette question cruciale des
témoins clés mais également les
documents qu'ils exigent de
l'administration trump une étape que les
républicains veulent remettre au plus
tard possible
merci dort abdelrazik en direct de
washington aux etats unis